we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i have a
couple of sad voicemails to play for you
today they are unfortunately from Bernie
supporters who are despondent after
super Tuesday's Fiasco only compounded
now Michael Bloomberg dropping out and
endorsing Joe Biden I believe it is over
and I know people will be furious
I believe it's over and I understand the
frustration take a listen to this hey
David after seeing the results of Super
Tuesday
I don't think Bernie's got it in them I
don't think he's gonna get the support
to win the nomination and I think that
his supporters they're not all of them
but the really loud ones online are very
delusional and are probably not going to
show up to vote especially for Joe Biden
when he went and I think we're screwed
I think Trump's gonna win re-election as
a result of this and I honestly think
that's secretly a lot of these Bernie
supporters that I'm referring to not all
of them obviously but the most loud
delusional ones actually supports from I
don't think they support Trump but I
think they would rather Trump over Joe
Biden which is not something I agree
with let's listen to another one of
these very sad messages hey David Steve
from Florida after a loss on Super
Tuesday for Bernie Sanders it
increasingly looks like Joe Biden may be
the nominee
given the coronavirus and people not
having health care do you think that his
path to victory needs to include
Medicare for all where he can abandon
his more centrist stance on enhanced
Obama care and moved to the left to
picked up Bernie supporters I I don't I
actually I actually think that what Joe
Biden is going to need to do
particularly if the kovat 19 outbreak
spreads is he's going to have to exact
explain exactly how those infected with
the virus would be able to afford care
for it as well as testing because the
issue of the testing and the cost of the
testing has become a big thing
he would have to explain how under his
plan that would work and whether we find
it believable whether we find that a
satisfactory explanation is obviously an
open question but I don't believe that
it is going to be necessary for Biden to
do that in the context of the broader
electorate remember and that is that
that's my take as of right now and of
course that could change is the
situation on the ground with coronavirus
such shifts and changes but I hear I
hear the despondency I hear it and it
was a very disappointing night for the
progressive movement as of right now
Elizabeth Warren is still in the race I
believe even if Elizabeth Warren drops
out that a significant portion of her
support actually doesn't go to Bernie
anyway so I know that this is being seen
as sort of look the last stand for
Bernie will Warren drop out so that
Bernie will gain her support I think
even with an endorsement of Bernie and
Warren dropping out I still think
probably anywhere from twenty to forty
percent of her support goes to bite in
anyway and with Bloomberg at this point
dropping out and endorsing Biden III
tell you guys you know in the in the
time it took us to film today's show
I've gone from it's an uphill battle for
Bernie but now as we've seen Bloomberg
drop and all of these other things
happen I believe that this is basically
the end of the road for Bernie Sanders
we've got to do the rest of the
primaries for sure but that's where I am
right now I want to be wrong tell me
where I'm wrong get in touch I just
don't see the numbers and we'll
certainly talk about this more on
today's bonus show I hope you will join
me we will also talk about Genki augers
results in the California 25th district
special election and a primary and so
much more
grab a membership at join pakman.com
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show